First Lady Melania Trump she is
hospitalized at Walter Reed Medical
Center at this hour after treatment for
a kidney problem the White House says
that doctors performed an embolization
to treat a benign condition mrs. Trump's
trip to the hospital was unannounced
ahead of time it is the most significant
medical procedure done on any sitting
first lady in more than 30 years the
president visited his wife yesterday
after tweeting successful procedure
she's in good spirits major Garrett is
at the White House major good morning
good morning with a recent state dinner
and last week solo Rose Garden event
about her b-best initiative First Lady
Melania Trump has raised her White House
profile now the first lady's office
would not disclose the first lady's
underlying medical condition but said
the surgical procedure to treat it and
her recovery likely to keep her at
Walter Reed for the remainder of this
week by the time President Trump headed
to the hospital Monday the first lady's
office had already announced that
Melania Trump successfully underwent an
embolization procedure to treat a benign
kidney condition CBS news chief medical
correspondent Jon LaPook said the
procedure is typically used to cut the
blood supply to a growth so it stops
growing in the days ahead they'll be
looking for any kind of complication
bleeding infection but the expectation
after a procedure like this generally is
for people to do very well the first
lady showed no signs of illness as
recently as late last week shield
welcomed three Americans freed from
North Korea and launched her new b-best
initiative let's encourage children to
dream big think big and do all they can
to be best in everything that they do
the president praising his wife she's
become a very very popular first lady
I'm reading Melania mrs. Trump is the
first first lady to undergo a serious
medical procedure since Nancy Reagan had
a mastectomy in 1987 Karl Anthony is a
First Lady historian often times when a
first lady suffers from a particular
illness or disease it sheds light on it
and provides more public awareness and
understand
particularly for those who may be
suffering or who may learn to recognize
symptoms well the first lady's office
say president Trump was not with Melania
Trump at the hospital for the procedure
he spoke with her beforehand and with
her doctor immediately afterward the
first lady's office said mrs. Trump
looks forward to making a full recovery
yep
we all want that for her today thank you
very much major